well it's January and that means
football playoffs are in full swing yeah
curious are you watching the NFL
playoffs Andy no well who do you thinks
gonna win the Super Bowl
I do not know yeah Andy you really
really don't know anything about sports
do you not at all going in then you know
what time it is I sure do
that's right it's time for Andy
Richter's sports blast
welcome to spark blasts let's bless and
sparks source this is a super special
edition of sports blasts sports because
it's the 2020 year in sports around 2020
here is sports Annie I'm confused we're
only two weeks into 2020 that's okay I'm
not gonna watch any sports this year
course let's start with this sport score
from last night 112 299 oh that means
it's time to head over to the wall
basketball wall of basketballs all right
hit me I'm open that means it's time to
check in with a green screen
correspondent trade trip the third the
third Hey hey Trey what cool green
screens have you got for us tonight well
right now it looks like I'm out of
basketball court sports now I'm in a
coral reef sports now on the moon sports
and now I'm inside the human colon you
know every year over 90,000 people are
diagnosed with colon cancer in 2020 Andy
Richter's sports blast sports encourages
everyone 14 years or older to get a
colonoscopy give a hoot check your shoot
get a home check your shoot back to you
Andy why do you gotta love green screen
sports hey watch the face and
colonoscopies
now let's go to sports blasts
correspondent Conan O'Brien with a list
of baseball downs and distances ha ha
thanks a lot hey watch it hey at third
and two sports 2nd and age sports 1st
and 15 sports
fourth and goal for third and 11 sports
second ninja's sports 4th and for sport
certain Broadway ports fourth in maybe a
foot here comes the lion crew and
imagine that no it's a first down thanks
Conan you know 2020 was a great year for
sport sports
so let's honor it now with a new segment
called Megan Rapinoe measures fish Megan
Rapinoe lizard fish largemouth bad
rainbow trout sports trans physios Danny
back to you but I hate you let's wrap it
up with the sports clip of the year
sports clip of sports sports sports
sports sports sports sports Wow
you got a lot of sports
well that's 2020 in a nutshell tune it
never again for another edition of Andy
Richter sports Blanche
[Applause]
from Butchie
from prague city and a new amazon
special the planet is burning Ilana
Glazer she will be right back
[Applause]